how can an influential and exclusive
business become more inclusive
educator and disability advocate sinead
burke is on a mission to change the way
fashion is represented in our world
[Music]
when this process first began which was
almost two years ago it was for a need
and an urgency for the national museums
of scotland because they were doing this
exhibition on the diversity of fashion
sinead has achondroplasia a form of
dwarfism and identifies as a little
person i asked how they were going to
exhibit my clothes
they said that they were going to hang
them from the ceiling i asked how
everything else was going to be
displayed and they said well
mannequins
so really almost flippantly i said okay
well how do we get a mannequin made
how cool is that it's amazing
i met with experts executives and
advocates in london and paris
who want to see the gilded doors of the
fashion business thrown open i certainly
experienced
tremendous racism i didn't fit the
very narrow profile of what was
acceptable
together we're going to explore not just
the moral argument
but the business case for letting
everyone in
what we wear says a lot about who we are
yet fashion is also a 2.5 trillion
dollar global industry that touches
everyone on earth
i'm imran ahmed i first started trying
to make sense of the fashion business 15
years ago as it was being transformed by
technology globalization and shifting
consumer values
now i'm on a journey to see how fashion
is recalibrating amid the pandemic
to balance profit with purpose
this is the business of fashion show
join me to discover how fashion shapes
business culture and identity
and to meet the people forging fashion's
future
[Music]
the luxury business is built on
exclusivity
fashion can appear inclusive in terms of
ethnicity
body shape and age
and designers may have shown a broader
light on beauty
but a caution about always taking
fashion at face value
analysis of thousands of images posted
by leading luxury brands on instagram
revealed that light-skinned models
continue to dominate fashion imagery
and when it comes to decision makers at
the top
in the design studio
or the boardroom
the seats of power remain largely
unchanged
it's good to witness visible and vocal
advocates
from trans icons
[Music]
to gender non-conforming people
fashion is doing more to count everyone
in
yet the business case for creating more
diversity inside fashion companies is
even more powerful
leading to higher levels of
profitability
businesses with the most ethnic and
gender diversity
outperform the least diverse by as much
as 36 percent
and they are much more likely to tilt
the lens to spot new business
opportunities
[Music]
such as a largely untapped 15 of the
world's population who have disabilities
and a spending power topping 1.2
trillion dollars
no wonder fashion is paying attention
the wider positive trend
boardroom diversity widens the
perspective at the top
entry-level pathways are no longer
reserved only for those who can afford
to take them
because the bottom line
to the benefit of shareholders in
society at large
is that belonging is good business
[Music]
since this is an episode about belonging
it's important to say a few things about
my own identity up front
i am an ismaili muslim man of indian
origin
born in canada to immigrants from east
africa
i was an outsider when i started
sneaking into fashion shows in 2005.
back then the front rows were a uniform
narrow representation of the world
[Music]
now i am invited into elite fashion
spaces where the front rows are changing
one stalwart is edward eninful the first
black man to be appointed as the
editor-in-chief of conde nast british
vote
at the paris couture shows i was also
reunited with samira nasser who became
editor-in-chief of harper's bazaar owned
by fashion's other media giant hurst
after a long day of shows we met to talk
about everything that has happened since
the beginning of the pandemic
including her rise to the very top of
fashion media
her premier issue was poignant examining
the paradox of being first
your appointment in this role was not
just a big change for you yeah it
represented pretty significant shift
for harper's bazaar yep for fashion
media the first woman of color
ever
in the history of harper's bazaar at the
helm
what did it mean to you personally but
what do you think it also signified for
all those young
women from different backgrounds who
never saw someone like you in a role
like this
i think
that
in that moment everyone felt seen i
think it was so much about me and you
know people rooting for me but i think
ultimately people were also rooting for
their likeness right it's an
acknowledgement of
all people who have felt
not seen and it just means that more
people can dream and aspire to something
that they never thought they could and
that's that's a beautiful thing what
does
real inclusion look like in fashion
walk down the street
to me that's is exactly what it should
mean you shouldn't be excluded because
where you come from or what you look
like or your sexual orientation or how
you identify yourself
it should just be are you willing to do
the work and do you have the passion to
try
that's what every industry should look
like back in the days when you first
started what was it like it was hard and
i certainly experienced you know
tremendous racism but
i just within the industry oh my gosh
yeah i've had some horrible things said
to me you know having to go meet an
editor a big big powerful editor and
uh
everyone's like okay you have to go meet
this editor and you know let's make sure
you look okay and then someone says
so and so editor
doesn't like messy hair
and so all the people who around me who
are trying to help me get ready are like
oh my god and i'm looking
who has messy hair
like who has missy hair and i realize
you know because my hair when it's out
is very big and i realize they're
talking about me and
you know that's just one example of
you know my natural texture hair was
messy you know i didn't fit the
very narrow profile of what was
acceptable so now that you're in the
role that you're in
you must feel a great sense of
responsibility this role isn't about me
it's about we it's about the community
that i can bring together
and share these platforms and elevate
you know these voices and and bring them
um bring them along with me so it's
about the we but i believe we all have a
responsibility it's like
you get through the door
and every one of us has the
responsibility to look back from where
you came and extend your hand right and
pull someone in with you but this
industry isn't entirely filled with
horrible people i feel like we have to
change that narrative also because i
love this industry why do you love this
industry it's everything it reflects our
times it is a community it's creative it
is a social commentary it's kind of a
social experiment really so many misfits
who find their way in and find their
voice and their place
and we get to dream you know we saw two
incredible shows today and
you know
those people are part of my community
yeah and we get to do that and we get to
do that cheers cheers
we'll always have couture we will
samira's idea of using her influence to
open doors for others sticks with me as
i head back to london
[Music]
every year the business of fashion hosts
a live event called voices our annual
gathering for big thinkers
in 2017 disability advocate sinead burke
addressed an audience of fashion leaders
and explained how the industry
systematically excludes disabled people
i have had an insatiable interest in the
fashion industry for as long as i can
remember
despite having such limited access to it
as founder and ceo of tilting the lens a
consultancy that brings visibility to
inaccessibility
sinead advises companies like gucci and
ralph lauren on moving from awareness to
action
when i meet with sinead in london we
start by reflecting on her journey from
voices and how her goals have changed
along the way
when you meet someone
now
how do you describe
who you are and what you do
it's funny i think
if we were having this conversation five
years ago i probably would have
described myself
first because of my visual identity in
the sense that i have dwarfism that i'm
a little person i'm a disabled woman
and whilst i still use that language i
probably talk about my interests and my
work more now
not because
those aren't defined by my disability
because they are
i understood that when people looked at
me they had assumptions over what i
could or couldn't do based on my
aesthetic
and i knew
within my own instincts that fashion had
this power to tell a new story
one that i had agency over because i'm
giving you permission to enter into my
world
to learn who i am
and yet despite knowing the power of
fashion to do that
i never felt represented or seen or able
to buy the clothes
that i felt comfortable in the
vulnerability that we've
shared with each other in private
moments
has really
emboldened me on my own purpose
in this industry and i was someone who
kind of put my own identity
in the background
some of the challenge around visible
identities is that as much as we try to
pocket them
the world still sees us as that i may
not describe myself as disabled but
the world sees me as disabled the
fashion system sees me as disabled and
me not
having pride around that
gives them permission to own whatever
narrative they think disability exists
within i imagine that's the same with
being muslim being gay being an
immigrant
tell me what happened
after
voices afterwards
i felt vulnerable
because i had exposed
myself mm-hmm
personally
but also professionally i had just told
the industry i knew what they needed to
do did i i didn't wait to you
have some sense
and what happened afterwards was
more and more conversations
initially with
individuals
than with brands and companies
it was appearing on stages with
microphone in my hand
going to fashion shows
it was
incredible
five years ago imran a few to ask me
what success was
i would have said the availability of
clothes
my vision has widened
i really do think the availability of
product is important
because i think it's
more important
that we are hiring disabled people
within these companies
that's what i want to change
voices like sineads matter but how do we
measure progress
one challenge is the lack of robust data
in the key european fashion economies of
france italy and germany companies
cannot collect personal data on identity
due to national privacy laws the uk goes
the furthest asking its citizens each
census to volunteer their racial
physical sexual and gender identities
so to continue our discussion sinead and
i meet with two leaders in british
fashion to share their own experiences
june sarpong is a broadcaster activist
author and the first director of
creative diversity at the bbc
jamie gill is ceo of luxury fashion
brand roxanda
both are non-executive directors of the
british fashion council appointed in the
wake of the black lives matter protests
june and jamie i just wanted to start
very quickly
you know maybe with you first june
you know how do you identify you know
what is your
personal story
my britishness in a way is a sort of the
link for me to the world you know it's
it's a wonderful
identity to be able to take with you
globally everybody sort of connects with
britishness um i would say my ghanaian
culture
for sure is my foundation that's my
roots um and then my race uh is
something that i am
so immersed in and with
um and also
impacts my experience in so many ways
jamie how about you uh how do you
identify identify
um i would identify myself as a
british indian
gay man i think and i'd add on londoner
yeah yeah i forgot that was one thing i
was thinking about it was like yeah we
say we're british but i think there's
you know as we all know there's a a
culture of being uh being from london
that i
that champion that i very much champion
and i think
growing up my whole life and and coming
from a working-class background as well
and growing up in the midlands and being
you know a minority on so many regards
um i saw those as just such hindrances
yeah such hindrances that i carried with
me that weighed me down than that you
know that didn't allow me to be free so
we're here talking about
belonging in the fashion industry
and you both all of us actually were
outsiders oh yeah all of us none of us
came up through a traditional path
but we've all found our way somehow into
this industry some people outside might
think we don't have a diversity problem
you know for that for that regard but
operationally the people from a
different any different kind of
background i think you know is very very
minimal and i think working in a kind of
smaller business but you know if we were
to look bigger and we would look at
you know listed companies out there and
even within the kind of fashion space as
well at c-suite you know it is
non-existent but are we at a point now
where we need measurables kpis like what
does success look like when it's
delivered
i don't think we have an example of
success yet and that's the issue
so we're asking people to imagine
something that perhaps in in any
industry actually has never really
existed at least not at scale
the first thing to do
is to connect with the most
disenfranchised
group within your organization
and ask them what their experience is of
your organization that's going to tell
you everything about your culture well
it raises a really interesting question
about our industry as a whole though is
like
this industry was designed
around exclusivity it is
so is there a way of reconciling that
exclusivity in terms of price or
scarcity or access or being in the room
with
inclusion and belonging and equity yes
in that
what it should have been designed around
is aspiration
in that it's about all of us
wanting to be the best version of
ourselves if you look at accessories
accessories are about aspiration
accessories are the entry point for
people who can't afford the actual
clothes etc etc they knew they had to do
that because of the financial benefits
why can't we apply that same thinking
for everything that we're talking about
here amongst this mono culture that
fashion still is especially on the
business side
how do we also do it in a way that
people aren't so
scared yeah when we talk about the
changes that are needed
we need to be really frank that
for those who have been used to
privilege
equity feels like a depression yes cindy
gallop but she's right
because
in order for others to take up space
some have to retract
so that pattern of behavior that they've
been practicing in terms of what
leadership won't work anymore no longer
exists so it's not that we need to
replace every ceo with somebody who
looks different that's not functional
nor is it practical nor is it the way we
need to move forward
we've got to do something visually very
externally projecting that we are
welcoming and there are roles available
at least that you know from the
operational side like what is it like
you know to be an operations director of
a fashion business you know and why does
that skill set actually maybe lean into
what you think you want to be doing so i
think we do need to be working on that
as a collective if we go back to the
ways in which we have always done things
what does it take
people to die
if we look at george floyd if we look at
the pandemic
it requires us to lose
people
in order to change
the great thing is is that between the
four of us
we can probably change a sizeable
portion of the world
with that on our minds sinead and i head
over to proportion london
one of the uk's largest manufacturers of
mannequins for the retail industry
today sinead is having the final casting
to complete a mannequin of her body
which can be used as a model for other
little people to be better represented
in fashion hello
gaetano this is imran imran this is
gaetano
hi how are you i am orion thank you for
having us it's fun it's such a treat
if you want to put this one on
this is going to be the most glamorous
bit of the entire fashion show
my couture has nothing on us gaytano
this is the second time you're doing
this right yeah so do you do you want to
tell us a little bit about how this
mannequin situation happened
so the national museums of scotland were
putting together this exhibition called
body beautiful they were the first ever
cultural institution to do an exhibition
about diversity and fashion and when it
came to disability they asked if they
could borrow some of my clothes and one
of those items was the trench coat which
i had actually saved from the business
of fashion shoot and i said how are you
going to display my clothes and the
initial suggestion was that they would
hang them from the ceiling
a lovely idea but i asked how was
everything else being displayed they
just said mannequins
i said okay great how do we get a
mannequin made
from my clothes
i can't tickle her right now right no
so after this mannequin is done what's
going to happen
my hope is that first we kind of tackle
the education system and that we're able
to collaborate with central st martin's
parsons fit the national college of art
and design in ireland to make these
available for students because if we
have
mannequins all of a sudden fit becomes a
different conversation and from then
like it would be great to see this
mannequin in retail spaces visually but
we need product first yeah you don't
have anything to put on the mannequin
yet no so putting it
putting clothes that may fit is one
thing but it needs to be in italians it
needs to be in design studios and we
need to be looking at this as a way in
which to get it into cad also and
thinking about the measurements
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
amazing
okay you see the that one yeah yeah
she's a little bit longer than this
yeah yeah
my mannequin is a composite
of me
my lumps my bumps my curves
me
and when i first saw the mannequin in
person
i was really insecure about it because
it didn't look like any of the
mannequins that i had seen and i was
almost joking about the size and the
measurements and i was uncomfortable
with it
but i'm not uncomfortable with me it's
the world making me feel like i don't
conform to everything else
and actually it's that discomfort that
proves the importance of this as soon as
you told me that this was happening i
wanted it to be a part of it and just
witness it because it felt pretty
monumental it wasn't until i saw all of
these mannequins
around me that i realized that in a
place like this where these body shapes
and these body types
are then replicated
over and over and over again and show up
in
retail stores
and in design studios
and in schools
that that's why we all develop these
ideas of what
body shapes should be
and it wasn't until seeing you
in this space that that
was reinforced for me
marginalized communities are not looking
for special treatment from fashion they
are looking for equal treatment
there are certainly powerful moral and
business arguments for doing so
but the question remains
how prepared is the fashion industry to
take real action
you